mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour et bien le temps des bougies et
des lampes à pétrole est maintenant
révolue pour certains habitants de
certains quartiers de cherbourg après la
tempête de vendredi le courant
électrique a été partiellement rétablie
hier soir vers 22 heures mais en même
temps qu'il revoyait la lumière ces
quelques privilégiés étaient invités par
haut parleur a usé le moins possible du
courant électrique car ce courant était
destiné en priorité à la remise en route
du chauffage des grands ensembles les
services de l'edf espère pouvoir
rétablir le courant aujourd'hui même cet
après midi dans tout cherbourg et dans
tout le cotentin
jeudi la situation redevient normale à
cherbourg dans le nord cotentin privé
d'énergie électrique depuis vendredi 23
heures les habitants de cette zone
sinistrée ont à nouveau eu de la lumière
hier soir vers 22 heures
c'est en fait un véritable tour de force
qui a été accompli par le personnel de
l'edf aider dans cette tâche par la
marine nationale et l'armée de terre
tour de force puisque les employés de
l'adf réussissait à doubler la puissance
de production qu'ils avaient espéré
pouvoir mettre en service
il faut encore savoir que pour que cette
situation redevienne normale
l'edf a reçu des renforts donnerait
parisienne un homme et en matériel cinq
groupes électrogènes entre autres et des
renforts de la région de tours de plus
dans les premières heures de la
catastrophe
l'arsenal maritime de cherbourg avait
mis tout en oeuvre pour que le service
de sécurité hôpitaux cliniques asile
fonctionnent normalement
l'armée de terre a mis tous les services
disponibles au service de l'adf ainsi
que la protection civile
le courant industrielle devrait être
rétablie demain dans la matinée ce qui
permettrait aux ouvriers de la région
cherbourgeoise jusqu alors en chômage
technique de reprendre le travail
aujourd'hui on poursuit la
réinstallation de lignes électriques
les employés sont appelés à travailler
de jour comme de nuit la vie reprend
petit à petit son cours normal dans
cette région malgré des prévisions
météorologiques pessimistes
on annonce à nouveau des chutes de neige
pour l'après midi et la nuit à venir
neige froid et verglas se sont abattues
hier sur l'auvergne où la tourmente de
neige a été particulièrement violente de
14h à 22h dans les régions montagneuses
du puy de dôme de la haute loire et du
cantal
le vent qui soufflait avec force a
entraîné la formation de congères de
plusieurs mètres obligeant les
chasse-neige à un va et vient incessant
mais malgré leurs efforts de nombreuses
voitures ont été immobilisées et
plusieurs villages isolés par de
véritables murs de neige la neige est
aussi tombée sur l'allier où l'on
circule et difficilement ce matin sur la
plupart des routes notamment dans la
région de gannat du donjon et de la
pallice où sévissent et le verglas
la température est heureusement remonter
de plusieurs degrés depuis le vert ce
matin provoquant un léger dégel en basse
altitude
cependant en montagne la situation sans
être alarmante demeure sérieuse et les
automobilistes sont invités à s'adresser
aux services de gendarmerie avant de
prendre la route
mais à quelque chose malheur est bon
puisque dans les stations d'hiver qui
affiche complet
la neige atteint une épaisseur de 2
mètres 50 au sommet des remontées et en
dépit du temps couvert les skieurs se
pressent nombreux sur les pistes
en fait on a du mal à trouver ce matin
coins de france où il n'est pas neigé la
neige est tombée un peu partout et
s'accompagne aussi de verglas ce qui
rend la circulation très difficile ainsi
pendant près de cinq heures 500 voitures
ont été bloqués hier soir du côté de
rive-de-gier entre saint-etienne et lyon
à paris les services de la voirie n'ont
pas épargné leurs efforts pour lutter
contre l'invasion de la neige 35 ares
aux municipales ont parcouru on l'a
calculé un peu près 800 km dans paris et
25 camions déversé 530 tonnes de sel sur
600 km de rues de boulevard et d'avenues
politique intérieure maintenant et bien
scepticisme dans les centrales
syndicales après les déclarations du
premier ministre monsieur jacques chaban
delmas qui a annoncé notamment son
intention de limiter à 3,9 pour cent les
augmentations l'augmentation des prix en
1970 à la cfdt monsieur jenson pense que
les travailleurs auront du mal à croire
que leur pouvoir d'achat a été
sauvegardé en 1969 et sera accrue en
1970 force ouvrière constate que le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs est
menacée par la hausse des prix qui
reprend une part importante des
revalorisations de salaires la
confédération générale des cadres
estiment que le pouvoir d'achat ne
dépend pas uniquement des prises et des
salaires et insiste sur la nécessité
d'une réforme de la fiscalité
enfin la cftc reconnaît que le pouvoir
d'achat des travailleurs du secteur
public a été à peu près maintenu en 1969
sauf pour les chargés de famille et la
cftc demande que désormais les
prestations familiales
suivent la même évolution que le coût de
la vie pas de réaction pour le moment du
côté de la cgt mais ce matin dans un
article publié par notre confrère
l'humanité monsieur georges séguy traite
de la situation sociale de secrétaire
général de la cgt reconnaît que certains
résultats appréciables ont été obtenus
dans le secteur privé à la suite de
négociations mais souligne que
l'ensemble des revendications
essentielles se heurte à la même
intransigeance gouvernementale et
patronale et monsieur séguy conclu il y
à du mécontentement dans l'air le
gouvernement et le patronat ce serait
bien avisé d'en prendre conscience et
d'examiner sérieusement avec les
organisations syndicales
les mesures à prendre depuis hier soir
21h huit cents cheminots sont en grève
de huit cents cheminots du dépôt
d'achères dans les yvelines ils
protestent contre la lenteur des
négociations à la sncf contre
l'insuffisance des propositions de la
direction
et enfin contre la compression des
effectifs à la sncf pour l'instant cette
grève n'a aucune incidence sur le trafic
de voyageurs en normandie le directeur
et le chef du personnel d'une usine sont
actuellement retenus par leurs ouvriers
qui sont en grève depuis plusieurs jours
cet après midi les grévistes doivent
rencontrer la direction
l'occupation hier du centre dauphine à
paris par une soixantaine d'étudiants
grévistes n'a pu durer que quelques
heures la police a fait évacuer les
locaux hier soir cette évocation
évacuation s'est déroulée sans aucun
incident et la grève du qui dure depuis
36 jours maintenant continue le compte à
rebours est commencé
vous n'avez plus que 11 heures devant
vous pour envoyer votre tiers
provisionnel à votre percepteur favori à
partir de ce soir 24 heures il y aura 10
% de plus pour les retardataires
juridiquement il n'y a plus d'affaires
anastasia la cour suprême d'allemagne
fédérale a rejeté l'appel interjeté par
madame henderson pour se faire
reconnaître comme fille du tsar nicolas
ii de russie un point final à moins
qu'il ne s'agisse de points de
suspension semble donc être mis à cette
affaire mais le mystère demeure
la pollution c'est un sujet qui est à
l'ordre du jour non parle beaucoup et
bien on va encore en parler sur les
côtes canadiennes ou un pétrolier a eu
quelques ennuis michel toulouse après
s'être échouées un pétrolier grec s'est
brisé en deux à cinq kilomètres des
côtes canadiennes
le bâtiment de 11000 tonneau transporté
18 millions de litres de pétrole qui se
sont répandus sur les plages le
gouvernement canadien rendu responsables
les deux compagnies qui exploitait le
navire et la facture de l'opération de
nettoyage leur sera envoyé
poissons et oiseaux de mer meurent par
milliers le premier souci des
techniciens et de brûler les nappe de
mazout au lance flamme de la paille de
verre est déversée sur le mazout pour le
rendre plus inflammable
mais la marée noire a déjà envahi le
rivage et des années pourront s'écouler
avant que la vie ne reprenne ses droits
sur les 18 km de plage
à
si la pollution par le mazout et
spectaculaire les états unis en
connaissent une plus insidieuse
l'envahisseur paraît bien anodin une
simple boîte de bière mais hélas elles
sont légion les etats-unis produisent 48
milliards de boîtes par an chaque
américain y compris les enfants et les
vieillards à 230 boîte à éliminer pas un
coin des états unis qui ne soit à l'abri
de ce nouveau genre d'envahisseurs le
moindre ruisseau charrie des boîtes de
bière qui rappelle que même dans les
coins les plus désert en à pique-niqué
dimanche dernier bien entendu les boîtes
disparaîtront un jour mais il faut dix
ou quinze ans quant aux nouvelles boîtes
en aluminium elles sont éternels les
archéologues futur les ex d'humour en
l'effleurant trôner dans quelques
vitrines
alors il faut trouver une solution les
américains pourraient ne pas voir de
bière mais le sacrifice et grands des
boîtes de bière qui se détruiraient
après consommation semble la solution
idéale mais les scientifiques n'ont pas
résolu ce problème
une expérience originale à los angeles
une firme d'aluminium rachète les boîtes
200 dollars la tonne un million de
boîtes par mois ont été récoltés ainsi
mais ce n'est pas assez
dans quelques années la france heurte
aura aussi à ce problème et la solution
n'est toujours pas trouvé oui ce
problème de la pollution ne se pose pas
uniquement aux états unis il se pose
également en france et 1970 enfants sera
l'année de la défense de la nature il ya
en france 300 points ou la cote dallaire
de la pollution est franchi et six
grandes régions où la vie animale est
gravement menacée de ce problème de la
protection de la nature georges valter
s'est entretenu avec le ministre de
l'agriculture monsieur jacques duhamel a
qui vient d'être confiée par le
président de l'unfp public une mission
de sauvegarde
ça c'est un peu votre carte d'état major
pour lou n'est ce pas cette carte
quelles sont les caractéristiques c'est
des zones noires peu nombreuses mémoires
des zones mauvaise quadrillé des zones
moyenne rayé et des zones dites
satisfaisante avec quelques coups de
poing à mon avis qu'est-ce qu'on peut
tout de suite déduire de l'analyse ou du
regard porté sur cette carte qui lie à
75 % des départements ou disons la
situation est satisfaisant
cela ne veut pas dire qu'elle est bonne
cela veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de points disons 300 points au
total
houcine axe
on vigoureuse est mené on ne peut dire
que les risques de pollution à ce moment
là sont cernés il ya au contraire 1 25 %
de cas qui sont mauvais et quelques uns
très sombre très noir blanc ça ça fait
peur alors la situation dans des régions
comme celle ci qui sont en noir le nord
ici la vallée de la seine je crois là
une partie la vallée du rhône
si nous sommes en saône-et-loire et
violent entre le lac léman et de fameux
lac du bourget il vient d'ailleurs que
ce lac du bourget talal déjà presque
mort les lac de lamartine vous parlais
tout à l'heure de l'angoissé de la
question que se posent et l'opinion
publique à cet égard il faut avertie
elle soit décidé ça veut dire décidé à
accepter les sacrifices les efforts que
cela implique mais sur le reste nous
avons les possibilités d'agir et je
pense que cela sera fait dans des délais
très raisonnable pour que la situation
de la pollution régresse au lieu et
place avec les données industrielles de
déversement les données agricoles aussi
de pesticides les données ménagères de
détergents la situation des eaux et nous
n'avons parlé pour le manque d eau
s'améliore au lieu de continuer à se
détériore ils sont d'ailleurs pas
uniquement des solutions nationales
d'après certaines rencontres que vous
avez lu le strasbourg il ya une raison
simple c'est la nature ne connaît pas de
frontières enfin je veux dire qu'un
certain nombre de fleuve ne connaissent
pas les frontières
le rêve landrin et effectivement il ya
quelques semaines à strasbourg nous
avons eu l'occasion en ouvrant l'une
l'année européenne de protection de la
nature de penser particulièrement à
strasbourg haut-rhin où les pollutions
d'ailleurs sont connus et où une action
européenne est nécessaire et j'ai eu la
satisfaction
il reste maintenant à voir l'action
devoir retenir par toutes les nations
qui étaient représentés à cette
conférence
l'idée que j'avais lancé d'un fonds
européen de lutte contre les pollutions
bon et bien voilà pour les pollutions
l'heure il reste maintenant la
conservation de moi j'aime pas beaucoup
de mots conservation je trouve ça un
côté purement négatif disons que la
protection elle a un côté offensif a un
côté promotionnel
il ne faut pas cet égard se dissimuler
que une action très importante est
amenée en particulier pour parler fort
et par et pour les forêts les forêts
sont une réserve
une réserve bien sûr pour la production
économique nous aussi une réserve pour
la halle équilibre biologique de l'homme
pour la détente aussi des personnes et
je crois que il est très important que
nous ayons une action offensive pour
essayer de garder la chlorophylle et
d'utiliser la forêt non seulement pour
les chasseurs et les fleuves pour les
pêcheurs détente essentiel équilibre
humain mais également pour essayer
d'abord d'éviter qu'on le perde le
patrimoine forestier et nous avons à cet
égard fait voter une loi qui pénalise le
défrichement et aux goûts très encourage
nos plantations et nous avons aussi une
politique de parcs nationaux en dehors
des forêts qui au fond on sort de la
même idée à savoir de valoriser
d'enrichir le paysage l'activité et en
particulier dans les milieux ruraux qui
ont déjà vous savez une tâche
fondamentale dans leur travail de
production aussi de conservation et
comment ne pas penser aux problèmes de
conservation des sols que l'agriculture
française concourt à faire dans
certaines régions de montagne où hélas
des drames récents nous ont montré que
la nature quelquefois se venger d'une
manière imprévisible
croyez vous que le public soit en
français soit mûr pour la discipline
pour adopter la discipline nécessaire il
suffit de regarder je ne sais pas l'état
du bois de boulogne paris et je crois
que les français quand ils prennent
conscience d'un problème sont capables
de trouver la solution de ce problème
je vous prends l'exemple des détritus du
bois de boulogne et c'est pour le mans
désespérant ce n'est pas limitée au bois
de boulogne
mais regardez puisque vous parlez de
paris qui n'est que partiellement la
france
regardez ce qui a été décidé un jour
d'arrêter les bruits et klaxon des
voitures lampard il ya ces effets du
jour hollande et on aurait pu dire
comment les français ne sont pas
disciplinés les parisiens sont
insupportables les auteurs mes blisson
bruyant ça s'est arrêté
donc je pense que la protection de la
nature peut être l'occasion pour
l'ensemble des français de redécouvrir
un sens civique quelquefois ils n'ont
pas ou qu'ils croient ne pas avoir comme
pour toute chose c'est à l'école que
tout commence et nous avons monsieur me
d'obligations nationale et moi-même un
projet
qui sera en application pour la rentrée
prochaine de vouloir justement organisée
dans chaque école primaire des
expositions où chaque classe et rades
enrichir l'exposition dont nous
fournirons les éléments de départ pour
essayer d'éduquer les parents sur ce
problème
à partir de la sensibilité des enfants
dit pareil de nos jours souvent les
enfants qui éduquent leurs parents et
bien là ça peut devenir vrai et fécond
et je pense beaucoup que les expositions
itinérantes que nous ferons seront une
occasion de sensibiliser les adultes et
par là même de leur faire eux-mêmes
décidé de la discipline nécessaire la
défense de la nature c'est également la
protection des animaux en particulier la
protection des espèces en voie de
disparition la migration des animaux
sauvages est un phénomène classique mais
encore assez mal connue pour sauvegarder
les espèces il faut mieux connaître
leurs coutumes et bien ce sera bientôt
chose faite car les états unis viennent
de mettre au point un système ingénieux
qui doit permettre de mieux surveiller
la migration des animaux sauvages en
pierre de gamme voici les perturbations
terrestre vue du satellite nimbus et en
regardant bien vous apercevrez peut-être
l'ouest des états unis un élan appelé
monique que voici
mais quel rapport entre un satellite et
un nul prenons les choses
au départ tout d'abord choisir et
endormir un anime les forestiers
choisissent une femelle parce que
distille elles sont plus de 6
seconde partie de l'opération la pose du
collier muni d'un émetteur radio que
déclenchera deux fois par jour le
satellite nimbus passant à 11 200
kilomètres d'altitude au dessus des
plaines du wyoming où monique vie dans
un troupeau de quelque 7000 in le
collier transmettra automatiquement des
informations sur la température ambiante
la température de la peau de la bête les
mouvements du troupeau et l'altitude où
il se trouve le satellite enregistrera
ses informations puis les enverra à
heure fixe à une station de l'alaska qui
elle même les enverra au centre des vols
spatiaux de la nasa à greenbelt où elles
seront analysées
ainsi grâce à monique n abuse la
migration des élans n'aura plus de
secret sport vous n'aurez le combat de
marcel cerdan serbe en aura bientôt plus
de secrets pour vous nous allons voir
comment marcel cerdan junior s'est
débarrassé d'un punching ball
l'inoffensive venu tout droit de porto
rico
il allie l pablo lópez c'est un
portoricain inconnu qui paraît-il est
boxeur professionnel inutile de vous
préciser la couleur de sa culotte lopes
est celui qui reçoit les coups et qui va
inter marcel cerdan celui qui les
donnent
d'ailleurs certains hier soir à boxer
intelligemment l'homme qu'il y était
opposé il ne touchait dès les premières
secondes et parachevait sa victoire au
début du deuxième renvoi 6
rien à dire contre serre dans le
scandale c'est surtout le fait de poser
de tels pantin aux français qui mérite
quand même mur et le public déchaîné n'a
pas caché son mécontentement et sa rage
même regarder et écouter
1970 xxème siècle quand même prouvé un
peu lent au début au premier rang à côté
quand je dois avouer que je n'ai pas
gagné comme ça il a envoyé pas de
signifier au tapis donc les habitants
d'ici mars elle passe sollicitera
contenu vous êtes bien langue celtique
donc au départ sur la majorité des
quolibets c'était pas pour votre boxeur
c'était pour moi je suis pas pourquoi
pourquoi pour moi je suis est ce que je
sais pourquoi sable mois si marseille
gagne avant la limite on peut dire
d'ailleurs que marseille ce soir vient
boxer mais son adversaire au début il a
peut-être pu faire impression pendant
quelques secondes et ensuite on savait
même pas ce que marcel a touché de suite
c'est tout voilà voilà un jeune qui
vient de faire deux fois le combat
vedette madison à new york il a 36
comment il a jamais été no 4 une fois il
un navire dit vous n'avez pas doisneau
et tout le monde vivait à new york même
ça va être dur pour marcel mais allez
lui demander à lui ce qu'ils pensent de
marseille donc mais il a été fait
exactement comme pour que pour ça pour
faire une thèse pour pour marcel pour
moi et vous le considérez maintenant je
mens après exactement aussi comme un
très bon test mais vous allez voir
demain la presse américaine est ce que
le dira le combat quant à lopez dépité
après le combat il repartira comme il
est arrivé en touriste
il ya quand même quatre mille
spectateurs qui sont repartis avec
sang-froid en moins car ils avaient payé
120 ans la place tout même pas très
sérieux il semble que c'est le prix des
places les plus coûteuses
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
pablo lopez ne tenait pas sur ses jambes
ça c'est manifestement ce pauvre match à
déchaîner la fureur du public
ce matin la presse n'est pas tendre du
tout avec les organisateurs et c'est
très normal car il est difficile
d'admettre que vous le dites dernier de
cazals que certains spectateurs payent
jusqu'à dix mille francs pour assister à
une parodie de combat car c'était
vraiment une parodie de combat afin
formation première va d'ailleurs ouvrir
le dossier de cette affaire et vous
pourrez assister ce soir en direct dans
le cas de télé nuit un débat excusez-moi
informations premier indice alors
qu'elle exalte le mans un débat qui
opposera philippe filippi à plusieurs de
nos confrères de la presse mais la
fédération est déjà une garantie pour
que de tels événements ne se
reproduisent plus à communiquer nous
parvient qui dit après le lamentable
spectacle offert hier soir sur le ring
du palais des sports de paris par
l'adversaire de ma salle cerdan la
fédération n'accordera pas
l'autorisation de combattre à paris au
boxeur professionnel américain qui
n'auront pas séjourné au moins sept
jours dans la capitale et qui ne se
seront pas soumis à certains tests
techniques et médicaux voilà savez qu'il
ya également un deuxième majeur je crois
que les au madison square garden les
spectateurs étaient beaucoup plus
content oui il y avait un match beaucoup
plus sérieux qui était décisif pour le
titre de champion du monde des poids
lourds l'américain le noir américain joe
frasier a battu jimmy eris par ko
technique à la fin du quatrième round
jimmy alice s'est montré assez dangereux
au début mais il fut rapidement dominé
par frasier le quatrième round fut le
dernier ancien employé des abattoirs de
philadelphie champion olympique à tokyo
j'aurai frasier de la le coup de grâce à
temps par deux fois que nous allons le
voir maintenant sur des images terribles
gauche à la mâchoire frasier envoyé
liste dans les cordes frasier continue à
marteler son adversaire la face et
l'église sur le tapis il se relève au
compte de 9 phrase et se ruent sur lui
et d'un autre gauche au menton expédie
elissa terre phrase y retourne dans son
coin les sens ellis allongé au sol
l'ambiance est au sommet frasier semble
prêt à bondir sur sa point sera sauvé
par le gong à 7 et au début du cinquième
round
ellis ne reprend pas le combat il reste
dans son coin tandis qu frasier saute
dans les bras de son manager yang drame
question se pose maintenant le nouveau
champion du monde affrontera t-il un
jour cassius clay invaincu mais déchu de
son titre pour avoir refusé de faire son
service militaire
cassius clay n'est toujours pas autorisé
à boxer ont dit que franchir va se
consacrer au rock and roll et à la pop
oui j'y pense et prochaine chez moi
c'est une plaisanterie de sa part parce
que c'est un garçon qui a une très très
belle carrière qui se vend encore devant
lui une information de ski une
information qui ne vous surprendra pas
tellement car après les championnats du
monde on assiste souvent à ce genre de
revirements médaille d'or à val gardena
by liquide a déjà décidé de passer
professionnel ils étaient des leaders du
combiné il va donc rejoindre pérignat
léo lacroix dans cette tournée deskur
professionnels disputera sa première
course à verbier
à la fin de la semaine encore du ski
mais du ski nordique
les championnats du monde de ski
nordique en tchécoslovaquie championnats
du monde de ski nordique en chypre
slovaquie sur les plateaux de hottes à
trun il ya les mêmes à japonais au
départ de l'épreuve de 30 km en france
ce sport est mal connue et l'on ne peut
se rendre compte de l'importance de ce
qui se passe là bas
en effet la supériorité nordique a été
fortement est entamée par les
soviétiques
voici viacheslav hénédine le vainqueur
vainqueur de cette épreuve de 30 km
c'est un lieutenant de l'armée
soviétique âgé de 29 ans déjà la veille
c'était un autre russe n'a pas le kof
qui avait remporté l'épreuve de saut au
tremplin moyens la course fut très dur
et vous allez voir qu'après ce terrible
effort lescure finissent complètement
épuisé la course pour le premier duras
en effet une heure 39 minutes une heure
et demie durant laquelle il faut marcher
sans relâche sur la neige sur ces
planches très minces que sont les skis
de fous complètement épuisé voici le
vainqueur qui précédera de 40 secondes
le second l'allemand gerhard gris mer
eh bien nous savons tout sur sa
discipline nordique merci patrick
chapuis jeanine alexandre nous allons
tous avoir aussi sur la page magazine de
ce journal oui aujourd'hui c'est la
chronique juridique de christiane
delacroix savait que les automobilistes
sont de plus en plus nombreux sur les
routes les accidents et la se
multiplient également
il est important de connaître ses droits
en la matière pas de jours que la presse
nous relativement de voitures et les
bilans de fin de semaine donne des
chiffres souvent impressionnant
lorsqu'il ya un accident qui a tort qui
est dans son bon droit
quels sont les recours possibles c'est
ce que nous allons essayer de voir
maintenant avec un avocat à la cour de
base m il y a le cas de la personne qui
sort précipitamment d'une voiture et qui
heurte un site historique ton lit
accident le cycliste est sérieusement
blessé quelles sont les responsabilités
si je trouve que c'est le propriétaire
lui-même qui ouvre la portière il est la
plupart du temps déclaré responsable
sauf une faute éventuelle à la charge du
cycliste si par exemple le cycliste
s'est faufilé dans un couloir à droite
entre la voiture qui était sur le point
de stationner et le trottoir il ya deux
automobilistes vous le savez qui
conduisent peut-être un peu négligemment
en posant le coude sur la portière
l'un d'eux a eu le bras arraché par une
voiture qu'ils croisaient quelles sont
les responsabilités de l'un et de
l'autre un violet ya une distinction à
fait j'ai connu effectivement une
affaire de ce genre où le l'accident
s'était produit entre deux véhicules
circulant en sens inverse qui ne tenait
d'ailleurs parfaitement leur droite ni
l'un ni l'autre mais on n'avait pas pu
déterminer le point de choc
or le conducteur propriétaire de la
voiture venant en sens inverse de celle
dont le conducteur a eu le bras arraché
car il l'avait posée sur sa portière a
été condamné à réparer entièrement le
dommages matériels causés à la voiture
mais en ce qui concerne le bras c'est de
dire le dommage corporel
il n'a été condamné qu'à la réparation
d'une part du point
10 car on a considéré qu'ils avaient la
part de celui qui avait posé son bras
sur la portière
une faute qui engageait pour une part sa
responsabilité sur la route les
collision entre deux voitures l'un des
passagers a été sérieusement blessé
peut-il se faire indemniser
et comment ils disposent de deux moyens
il peut d'abord déposer une plainte
cette plainte sera suivi on inculpera
l'un ou l'autre l'a fait reviendra en
correctionnelle en correctionnelle il se
constituera partie civile et demandera
l'indemnisation son préjudice
il peut aussi usé de la voie civile et
faire un procès devant le tribunal de
grande instance statuant en matière
civile
la différence entre les deux est très
difficile à vous exposer c'est un
problème de preuve mais c'est aussi un
problème de prescription dans le premier
cas il doit déposer sa plainte dans le
délai de trois ans et dans le second cas
il dispose d'un délai de trente ans pour
faire son action à propos de circulation
en vacances de neige il existe des
difficultés à circuler sur les pistes de
ski actuellement parce que la foule se
porte sur six pistes actuellement
existe-t-il un code de ski ou des règles
qui déterminent les responsabilités de
chacun qui n'existe pas actuellement de
codes du ski mais étant donné
l'importance le développement pris par
les sports d'hiver
le nombre de personnes qu'on voit
circuler sur six pistes mille personnes
sur le flanc d'une montagne nécessite
effectivement l'instauration de règles
comme il n'existe pas de code
mais qu'il faut bien déterminer les
responsabilités actuellement ce sont des
tribunaux et les cours qui sent